Jon Favreau's The Jungle Book released
this weekend and while King Louie might
be hungry for man's red fire
it appears that Disney are more than
satisfied with man's green cash I'm
Simon and trust in me with your jungle
news update Disney's new movie The
Jungle Book has swung to the top of the
box office this weekend the film which
mixes live action with cutting-edge 3d
animation has scored the second highest
ever
April opening pulling in a massive 100
and 3.6 million dollars the weekend
gross goes beyond the estimated figures
which as Collider notes had the film
topping out at a maximum of 85 million
dollars the film is now second only to
Furious 7 in terms of an April opening
worldwide it has to date made 290 point
9 million dollars the film which is
directed by Iron Man's Jon Favreau and
based on the classic stories of Roger
Kipling has been backed by extremely
strong reviews and much acclaim for its
use of 3d and CGI the all-star voice
cast includes Bill Murray Ben Kingsley
Idris Elba Lupita Nyong'o Scarlett
Johansson and Christopher Walken plus
newcomer Neel Sethi as Mowgli The Jungle
Book is the latest classic fairy tale
that Disney is retold for modern
audiences Tim Burton's Alice in
Wonderland earned more than 1 billion
dollars in 2010 and a sequel is due in
cinemas next month further down the line
Beauty and the Beast starring Emma
Watson is set for release in March 2017
what the success of the jungle book
means for the rival adaptation from
Warner is unclear that film has already
been moved back in entire year to
October 2018 and a report in variety
quotes a source as saying that the
popularity of the Disney film could
spell disaster for the Warner version
would you like to see Warner's
interpretation of the classic Jungle
Book story or would you rather see a
sequel to Jon Favreau's vision let me
know in the comments below or find me on
Twitter I'm at the J g'nort thanks for
watching and for all your entertainment
news keep it gamespot